I don't like to think too far ahead and
people say it like goals long-distance
goals and [ __ ] that's too much for me I
already feel like I'm living it and then
I just carry on the old I you know carry
on day by day already living the final
goal the goal of being the world champ
and I already carry myself like I'm my
world champ and I already speak like I'm
a world champion and and that's it I
just carry on day by day so I'll take
her as a corpse again like I said you
were awesome ask me about the future
I'll let you I'll let you know a little
bit closer all I can see right now is
the cold that's all I can see there's
parents coming in with their kids from
like da Hoyt bring them into the gym
Amanda but I saw it encouraging as never
like that that's gonna go to a next
level when you have the parents
encouraging the dream and regardless of
people again people can say it's
barbaric and martial arts is barbaric or
this game is too it's too much be
anonymous two men beating each other or
whatever the martial arts life will give
you a discipline will give you
dedication will give you a drive that
you won't get nowhere else so whatever
these kids that come in that's us with
our parents whatever they decide to do
where they decide to conquer the martial
arts world the fighting game or whether
they want to go and conquer the business
world whatever they decide to do
training for combat sport training
martial arts will give them that
confidence to go and excel and anything
so people can can criticize the better
all they want but the results speak for
themselves and seeing these little kids
come in this size it's it's good times
good times ahead I see you just watched
two amazing clips from Conor McGregor
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly I think about how to apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]